willkommen zurück bei „Understanding Quantum Information and Computation" – mein Name ist John Watus und ich bin der technische Direktor für Bildung bei IBM
Quantum. Dies ist Lektion Nummer 14 der Serie und die zweite Lektion der vierten Einheit, die sich mit Quantenfehler-
korrektur befasst. In der vorherigen Lektion haben wir uns erstmals mit der Quantenfehlerkorrektur beschäftigt, einschließlich des neun-qubit Shore-Codes, der zeigt, dass
Quantenfehlerkorrektur theoretisch möglich ist. Wir haben auch die Diskretisierung von Fehlern besprochen, die es uns ermöglicht,
beliebige Quantenfehler auf qubits zu korrigieren, indem wir sie effektiv auf Bit-Flips und Phasen-
Flips projizieren. In dieser Lektion werden wir den Stabilisatorformalismus besprechen, ein mathematisches Werkzeug, mit dem wir
eine breite Klasse von Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes, sogenannte Stabilisatorcodes, spezifizieren und analysieren können. Dazu gehört der 9-qubit Shore-
code sowie viele weitere Beispiele, einschließlich Codes, die für reale Quanten-
Computer wahrscheinlich deutlich besser geeignet sind als der Shore-Code. Nicht jeder Quantenfehlerkorrekturcode ist ein Stabilisatorcode, aber viele sind es –
darunter jedes Beispiel, das wir in dieser Serie sehen werden. Es gibt sicherlich interessante und potenziell nützliche Quantenfehler-
korrektircodes, die keine Stabilisatorcodes sind, aber sie sind in der Regel deutlich komplizierter. In jedem Fall besteht kein
Zweifel, dass der Stabilisatorformalismus ein Eckpfeiler der Grundlagen der Quantenfehlerkorrektur ist, und wir werden
ihn für den Rest der Einheit intensiv nutzen. Hier ist ein kurzer Überblick über die Lektion: Wir beginnen mit einer kurzen Diskussion
über Pauli-Matrizen und Tensorprodukte von Pauli-Matrizen, die sowohl Operationen auf qubits als auch
Messungen von qubits darstellen können – wie ich erklären werde. In diesem Zusammenhang bezeichnen wir sie oft als Observablen. Wir werden dann zurückgehen und
einen zweiten Blick auf den Wiederholungscode werfen und sehen, wie wir ihn durch Pauli-Operationen und Observablen beschreiben können. Das wird sowohl
als Grundlage dienen als auch in eine allgemeine Diskussion über Stabilisatorcodes führen, einschließlich mehrerer Beispiele und grundlegender Eigenschaften von Stabilisator-
codes sowie der Frage, wie wir die grundlegenden Aufgaben des Kodierens, Erkennens von Fehlern und Korrigierens dieser
Fehler durchführen können. Wir beginnen die Lektion mit einer kurzen Diskussion über Pauli-Operationen, hauptsächlich um die Grundlage für den
Stabilisatorformalismus zu legen, aber auch um einige wichtige Fakten zu beobachten und grundlegende Terminologie einzuführen. Zunächst hier die Pauli-
Matrizen, einschließlich der 2x2-Einheitsmatrix sowie der drei Nicht-Einheits-Pauli-Matrizen, die wir mit
Großbuchstaben X, Y und Z bezeichnen werden – durch den Rest der Serie. Alle vier dieser Matrizen sind sowohl unitär als auch hermitesch, und wir können
sie mit Operationen auf einem qubit identifizieren, einschließlich Operationen, die wir bewusst ausführen möchten, sowie Fehlern, wie
wir in der vorherigen Lektion besprochen haben. Die Nicht-Einheits-Pauli-Matrizen X, Y und Z antikommutieren miteinander,
was bedeutet, dass XY gleich -1 * YX ist, XZ gleich dem Negativen von ZX ist, und YZ gleich
dem Negativen von ZY ist. Du kannst diese Relationen leicht überprüfen, indem du die Multiplikationen durchführst. Diese Antikommutations-
relationen sind sehr einfach, aber im Stabilisatorformalismus und anderswo von entscheidender Bedeutung, und zwar insbesondere
– wie wir sehen werden – entsprechen diese Minuszeichen, die auftauchen, wenn wir die Reihenfolge zweier verschiedener Nicht-Einheits-Pauli-Matrizen in einem Produkt vertauschen, genau der
Fehlererkennung im Stabilisatorformalismus. Wir haben auch die hier aufgelisteten Multiplikationsregeln: Jede
Pauli-Matrix ist ihre eigene Inverse, was mit der Tatsache übereinstimmt, dass sie sowohl unitär als auch hermitesch sind. Und wenn du zwei verschiedene Nicht-Einheits-
Pauli-Matrizen miteinander multiplizierst, erhältst du immer plus oder minus I mal die verbleibende Nicht-Einheits-
Pauli-Matrix. Insbesondere ist Y bis auf eine globale Phase äquivalent zu X mal Z, was unseren Fokus auf X- und Z-Fehler bei der
Quantenfehlerkorrektur erklärt. X stellt einen Bit-Flip dar, Z stellt einen Phasen-Flip dar, und somit stellt Y bis auf eine globale Phase
beide dieser Fehler dar, die auf demselben qubit auftreten. Diese vier Matrizen stellen alle
Operationen oder Fehler oder das Ausbleiben eines Fehlers auf einem einzelnen qubit dar, aber es ist oft praktisch, sie miteinander zu tensorieren,
um Operationen oder Fehler auf mehreren qubits durchzuführen. Als Terminologiehinweis: Wenn wir von einer N-qubit-Pauli-
Operation sprechen, meinen wir ein Tensorprodukt von beliebigen n Pauli-Matrizen, wie die hier gezeigten Beispiele
verdeutlichen. Es ist auch üblich, den Begriff Pauli-Operation zu verwenden, wenn eine globale Phase vorhanden ist, aber um die Dinge so einfach wie möglich zu halten,
werde ich den Begriff Pauli-Operation verwenden, um einfach ein Tensorprodukt von Pauli-Matrizen zu bezeichnen. Das Gewicht einer N-qubit-Pauli-
Operation ist einfach die Anzahl der Nicht-Einheits-Pauli-Matrizen im Tensorprodukt. Zum Beispiel ist das n-fache Tensor-
produkt der 2x2-Einheitsmatrix mit sich selbst eine Pauli-Operation mit Gewicht null. Ein Tensorprodukt von zwei Pauli-X-
Matrizen und einer Reihe von Einheitsmatrizen hat Gewicht zwei, und so weiter. Intuitiv gesprochen ist das Gewicht einer N-
qubit-Pauli-Operation die Anzahl der qubits, auf die sie nicht-trivial wirkt. Typischerweise werden Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes so
konzipiert, dass sie Fehler erkennen und korrigieren können, die durch Pauli-Operationen bis zu einem bestimmten Gewicht dargestellt werden. Wir können
Pauli-Operationen auf verschiedene Arten betrachten, unter anderem als absichtlich durch Quantum Gates durchgeführte Operationen sowie
als Fehler. Außerdem werden wir in Kürze sehen, dass Pauli-Operationen auch Messungen beschreiben können. Manchmal ist es auch nützlich,
Pauli-Operationen als Erzeuger bestimmter Mengen in einem algebraischen Sinne zu betrachten, den du vielleicht kennst,
wenn du mit Gruppentheorie vertraut bist. Falls du nicht mit Gruppentheorie vertraut bist – kein Problem, sie ist wirklich nicht essenziell
für diese Lektion. Aber wenn du daran interessiert bist, die Quantenfehlerkorrektur eingehender zu studieren, wirst du möglicherweise feststellen, dass einige
grundlegende Gruppentheorie dabei sehr hilfreich ist. Nehmen wir jedenfalls an, dass P1 bis PR N-qubit-Pauli-Operationen sind –
P1 ist also eine N-qubit-Pauli-Operation, P2 ist eine N-qubit-Pauli-Operation, und so weiter. Wenn wir von der durch
P1 bis PR erzeugten Menge sprechen, meinen wir die Menge aller Matrizen, die wir durch Multiplikation dieser Matrizen
in beliebiger Kombination und in beliebiger Reihenfolge erhalten können, wobei wir jede beliebig oft verwenden können. Wir werden gleich ein paar Beispiele sehen,
aber zunächst möchte ich die Notation erwähnen, die wir verwenden, um diese Menge zu bezeichnen: die von P1 bis PR erzeugte Menge wird durch
P1 bis PR, durch Kommas getrennt, innerhalb spitzer Klammern dargestellt. Das sieht zwar so aus, als könnten wir diese
Notation leicht mit der Dirac-Notation verwechseln, aber das passiert im Allgemeinen nicht, und dies ist die traditionelle Notation in der Gruppen-
theorie. Hier ist ein Beispiel der von X, Y und Z erzeugten Menge – n ist in diesem Beispiel gleich eins, da es keine
Tensorprodukte gibt und wir alle drei Nicht-Einheits-Pauli-Matrizen als Erzeuger verwenden. Es stellt sich heraus, dass es
16 Matrizen gibt, die durch Bildung von Produkten mit diesen drei Matrizen erzeugt werden können, und du kannst das
anhand der Multiplikationsregeln, die wir zuvor gesehen haben, nachvollziehen. Konkret können wir natürlich X, Y und Z sowie die Einheitsmatrix erhalten,
und tatsächlich können wir auch jede dieser vier Matrizen mal I, 1 oder dem Negativen von I erhalten – und das ergibt
diese Menge ist allgemein bekannt als die Pauli-Gruppe, wir könnten auch die Menge betrachten,
die nur durch x und z erzeugt wird, und erhalten in diesem Fall die Hälfte der Pauli-Gruppe
und ein letztes Beispiel, zumindest für jetzt: wir können die Menge betrachten, die durch X tensor x und z tensor Z erzeugt wird, also ist n gleich
zwei in diesem Fall, und wir erhalten diesmal nur vier Elemente, da X tensor x und z tensor Z
miteinander kommutieren. Pauli-Matrizen und n-qubit-Pauli-Operationen beschreiben allgemeiner
unitäre Operationen, ob es sich um Fehler oder um absichtliche Operationen handelt, aber sie beschreiben auch
Messungen. Genauer gesagt, beginnend mit nur den drei Nicht-Identitäts-Pauli-Matrizen, können wir jede dieser
Matrizen mit einer projektiven Messung verknüpfen, die durch ihre Eigenwerte und Eigenvektoren definiert ist, und hier auf dem Bildschirm
sehen wir Spektralzerlegungen dieser Matrizen, die das verdeutlichen werden. Im Wesentlichen meinen wir mit einer X-
Messung, einer Y-Messung oder einer Z-Messung die projektive Messung, die durch die Projektionen
auf die Eigenräume dieser Matrizen definiert ist, und üblicherweise betrachten wir die Eigenwerte als die entsprechenden
Messergebnisse. Zum Beispiel ist eine X-Messung eine Messung bezüglich der Plus-
Minus-Basis eines qubit, oder alternativ können wir sie durch die Menge beschreiben, die die Projektionen Ket-plus-Bra-plus und K
minus-Bra-minus enthält. Eine Z-Messung hingegen ist nichts anderes als eine Standardbasis-
Messung, obwohl wir, wie ich sagte, manchmal die Eigenwerte mit den Messergebnissen identifizieren, und wenn wir das tun,
dann sind die Ergebnisse plus und minus eins anstelle von 0 und eins beziehungsweise. Wir können tatsächlich etwas
in dieser Richtung für beliebige hermitesche Matrizen tun, und der Begriff Observable wird in dieser Situation für Pauli-
Matrizen und n-qubit-Pauli-Operationen allgemein häufig verwendet. Wir können solche Messungen nicht-destruktiv durchführen, indem wir
Phasenschätzung verwenden, und nur um sicherzustellen, dass dieses Diagramm klar ist: hier führen wir die Messungen nicht-destruktiv an
dem oberen qubit durch, während das untere qubit immer auf einen Plus-Zustand initialisiert wird, also mit anderen Worten ein Hadamard angewendet auf einen
Null-Zustand, da das so funktioniert, wie Phasenschätzung arbeitet. Beachte, dass, weil die Eigenwerte
in diesem Fall nur plus eins und minus eins sind, wir nur ein Steuer-qubit benötigen, das das untere qubit in diesem
Diagramm ist. Mehr als das wäre nur eine Verschwendung, weil es nur ein Bit Präzision zu beachten gibt. Der Eigenwert
ist entweder plus eins oder minus eins, und die Messung ist bereits perfekt, genau so. Das Ergebnis dieser Messung,
übrigens die Standardbasismessung im circuit, ist null für das Eigenwert-Ergebnis plus eins,
was dem Plus-Zustand im Fall einer X-Observable entspricht, und das Ergebnis ist eins für den negativen Eigenwert
oder den Minus-Zustand in diesem Fall. Alles, was ich gerade gesagt habe, lässt sich natürlich auf n-qubit-Pauli-Operationen erweitern,
vorausgesetzt, wir behalten im Hinterkopf, dass wir, wenn wir über eine Observable sprechen, die Eigenwerte messen,
nicht bezüglich einer Basis von Eigenvektoren messen. Betrachte zum Beispiel die zwei-
qubit-Pauli-Operation Z tensor Z. Wieder gibt es zwei Eigenwerte, plus eins und minus eins, also wird die
Messung durch zwei Projektionen beschrieben. Beachte insbesondere, dass die Messung, die wir mit
dieser Observable verknüpfen, nicht dasselbe ist wie das Messen beider qubits mit einer Z-Messung, also einer Standardbasismessung, sondern es ist eine Zwei-
Ergebnis-projektive Messung, bei der die Projektionen auf die Räume projizieren, die von allen Eigenvektoren aufgespannt werden, die dem
jeweiligen der beiden Eigenwerte plus eins und minus eins entsprechen. Eine andere Denkweise ist, dass die Eigenwerte eines Tensor-
produkts Produkte der Eigenwerte der einzelnen Matrizen sind, von denen wir die Tensorprodukte nehmen, und
da negativ 1 mal negativ 1 dasselbe ist wie positiv 1 mal positiv 1, unterscheidet diese Messung zum Beispiel nicht
zwischen 0 0 und 1 1. Wenn wir also zum Beispiel einen Phi-plus-Bell-Zustand mit der Messung messen würden,
die durch diese Observable beschrieben wird, wären wir sicher, das Ergebnis zu erhalten, das dem Eigenwert plus eins entspricht,
und der Zustand wäre unverändert, im Gegensatz zum Kollaps auf 0 0 oder 1 1, was passieren würde, wenn wir
die Standardbasismessungen an den beiden qubits durchführen würden. Eine Z-tensor-Z-Messung ist also nicht
dasselbe wie das unabhängige Durchführen von zwei Z-Messungen, aber wir können solche Messungen tatsächlich mit Phasen-
schätzung durchführen, auf genau dieselbe Weise wie zuvor, mit einem einzigen Steuer-qubit, wie im circuit-Diagramm gezeigt wird, das
sich auf jede n-qubit-Pauli-Operation anstelle von Z tensor Z verallgemeinert. Wenn wir nur Z-Pauli-Matrizen haben,
können wir den circuit übrigens so vereinfachen, und was das zeigt, was auch aus den Projektionen ersichtlich ist, die die
Messung definieren, ist, dass das Durchführen einer Z-tensor-Z-Messung an zwei qubits gleichwertig ist mit dem Messen ihrer Parität
im Sinne der Standardbasis, und das verallgemeinert sich auf das Tensorprodukt beliebig vieler Pauli-Z-
Matrizen. Als Nächstes werfen wir einen zweiten Blick auf den Drei-Bit-Repetitionscode, diesmal formuliert in Bezug auf Pauli-
Operationen. Dies wird unser erstes, recht einfaches Beispiel eines Stabilisatorcodes sein, und wir werden besprechen, wie man diesen
Begriff in Kürze verallgemeinern kann, aber es ist hilfreich, zuerst zu sehen, wie es in diesem einfachen Fall funktioniert. Erinnere dich daran: wenn wir den
3-Bit-Repetitionscode auf qubits anwenden, kodieren wir einen gegebenen qubit-Zustand Alpha 0 plus Beta 1 als Alpha 000 plus Beta 111
und wir werden dieser Drei-qubit-Kodierung der Einfachheit halber den Namen Psi geben. Per Definition ist Psi also eine gültige Drei-qubit-
Kodierung eines qubit-Zustands, aber wenn wir das überprüfen wollen, reicht es aus zu überprüfen, dass die folgenden zwei Gleichungen wahr sind. Die
erste Gleichung besagt, dass das Anwenden von Z-Operationen auf die beiden am weitesten links stehenden qubits von Psi nichts an Psi ändert, das heißt,
Psi ist ein Eigenvektor von Z tensor Z tensor Identität, oder kurz ZZ-Identität, mit Eigenwert eins, und die zweite
Gleichung ist ähnlich, außer dass Z-Operationen auf die beiden am weitesten rechts stehenden qubits angewendet werden. Die Idee ist, wenn wir Psi
als Linearkombination von Standardbasiszuständen betrachten, dann impliziert die erste Gleichung, dass wir nur Nicht-Null-Koeffizienten für Standardbasiszustände haben können,
bei denen die beiden am weitesten links stehenden Bits gerade Parität haben oder gleichwertig gleich sind, und die zweite Gleichung impliziert, dass wir nur
Nicht-Null-Koeffizienten für Standardbasiszustände haben können, bei denen die beiden am weitesten rechts stehenden Bits gerade Parität haben. Eine andere Denkweise ist,
diese beiden Pauli-Operationen als Observablen zu betrachten, und wenn wir diese beiden Observablen mit dem
vereinfachten circuit messen würden, den ich gerade erwähnt habe, wären wir sicher, ein Messergebnis zu erhalten, das den Eigenwerten plus eins entspricht,
da Psi ein Eigenvektor beider Observablen mit Eigenwert eins ist. Aber diese vereinfachte Version des kombinierten
circuit für das unabhängige Messen der Observablen ist nichts anderes als unser Paritätsprüf-circuit für den 3-Bit-
Wiederholungscode, und so sehen wir, dass unsere beiden Gleichungen zusammen äquivalent dazu sind, dass der Paritätsprüf-circuit 0 0 ausgibt
was das Syndrom ist, das anzeigt, dass keine Fehler erkannt wurden – die drei-qubit-Poly-Operationen
ZZ-Identität und Identität-ZZ werden Stabilisatorgeneratoren für diesen Code genannt, und der Stabilisator des Codes ist die Menge
die von den Stabilisatorgeneratoren erzeugt wird. Diese Menge – der Stabilisator – ist ein grundlegend wichtiges mathematisches
Objekt, das mit diesem Code verbunden ist, und wir werden die Rolle, die er spielt, im weiteren Verlauf der Lektion besprechen. Fürs Erste
möchte ich nur darauf hinweisen, dass wir eine andere Wahl für die Generatoren hätten treffen können – zum Beispiel hätten wir Z-Identität-Z anstelle eines der
von uns gewählten Generatoren wählen können, und der Code und der Stabilisator wären exakt gleich. Als Nächstes betrachten wir die Bit-Flip-
Erkennung für den Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode mit dem Fokus auf den Wechselwirkungen und Beziehungen zwischen den Poly-
Operationen, die dabei beteiligt sind – nämlich den Stabilisatorgeneratoren und den Fehlern selbst. Angenommen, wir haben ein
qubit mithilfe des Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscodes kodiert, und ein Bit-Flip-Fehler tritt auf dem ganz linken qubit auf. Das führt dazu, dass unser Zustand Ψ
gemäß der Wirkung einer X-Operation bzw. eines X-Fehlers auf dem ganz linken qubit transformiert wird. Wie wir bereits wissen, können wir
diesen Fehler erkennen, indem wir die Paritätsprüfungen für den Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode durchführen, oder äquivalent dazu können wir die
Kodierung nicht-destruktiv messen, indem wir die Stabilisatorgeneratoren als Observable behandeln. Fangen wir mit dem ersten
Stabilisatorgenerator an und schauen, was passiert. Unser Zustand wurde durch einen X-Fehler beeinflusst, und wir möchten verstehen,
wie die Messung des Stabilisatorgenerators als Observable durch diesen Fehler beeinflusst wird. X und Z antikommutieren, während
alles mit der Identitätsmatrix kommutiert, und daraus folgt, dass ZZ-Identität mit X-Identität-
Identität antikommutiert. Wir erhalten also ein Minuszeichen, wenn die Reihenfolge vertauscht wird, und wir wissen auch, dass ZZ-Identität nichts an S ändert,
weil S eine gültige Kodierung eines qubit ist und gültige Kodierungen immer Plus-Eins-Eigenvektoren beider Stabilisator-
generatoren sind. Das lässt uns mit einem negativen X-Identität-Identität, angewendet auf S, und daher ist X-Identität-Identität, angewendet auf
S, ein Eigenvektor von ZZ-Identität mit dem Eigenwert minus eins. Wir können etwas Ähnliches auch
mit dem zweiten Stabilisatorgenerator machen, aber diesmal kommutiert der Fehler mit dem Stabilisatorgenerator, und daher ist unser
korrumpierter Zustand erneut ein Eigenvektor des Stabilisatorgenerators, aber diesmal ist der Eigenwert positiv
eins. Unser korrumpierter Zustand ist also ein Eigenvektor beider Stabilisatorgeneratoren, und ob der Eigenwert plus eins oder
minus eins ist, wird dadurch bestimmt, ob der Fehler mit jedem Stabilisatorgenerator kommutiert oder antikommutiert. Beim ersten
antikommutieren der Fehler und der Stabilisatorgenerator, und beim zweiten kommutieren sie – und es wird immer eines von beidem sein, weil zwei beliebige
Poly-Operationen entweder kommutieren oder antikommutieren. Der eigentliche Zustand Ψ spielt dabei keine wirklich wichtige
Rolle, außer der Tatsache, dass die Stabilisatorgeneratoren trivial auf diesen Zustand wirken. Wenn wir also über die
Erkennung von Fehlern nachdenken, müssen wir uns nicht wirklich mit dem spezifischen kodierten Zustand befassen – alles, was zählt, ist, ob der Fehler kommutiert oder anti-
kommutiert mit jedem Stabilisatorgenerator. Erstellen wir also eine Tabelle mit einer Zeile für jeden Stabilisatorgenerator
und einer Spalte für jeden Fehler. Hier habe ich nur die Fehler berücksichtigt, die einem einzelnen Bit-Flip entsprechen, sowie
keinen Fehler, der durch die Identität, tensored mit sich selbst drei Mal, angezeigt wird. Wir könnten weitere Spalten für andere Fehler hinzufügen, wenn wir möchten,
aber für jetzt beschränken wir uns auf genau diese Fehler. Der Eintrag in der Tabelle ist entweder plus eins oder minus eins, je nachdem ob
der Fehler und der Stabilisatorgenerator kommutieren oder antikommutieren. Für jeden Fehler in der Tabelle können wir also auf
die entsprechende Spalte schauen, um zu sehen, wie dieser Fehler jede beliebige Kodierung in einen Plus-Eins- oder Minus-Eins-Eigen-
vektor jedes Stabilisatorgenerators transformiert. Diese Spalten entsprechen genau dem Syndrom, das wir aus den
Paritätsprüfungen erhalten würden, welche äquivalent zu den nicht-destruktiven Messungen der Stabilisatorgeneratoren als
Observable sind. Natürlich sind die Einträge in dieser Tabelle plus eins und minus eins und nicht null und eins
– und wenn du möchtest, kannst du dir die Syndrome als die entsprechenden binären Zeichenketten vorstellen, anstatt als Spalten von plus eins und minus eins. Aber es gibt eine
direkte Entsprechung, und um die Verbindung zwischen den Syndromen und den Eigenwerten klarer und direkter zu machen,
werde ich diese Vektoren aus plus eins und minus eins wie zuvor als Syndrome bezeichnen. Die Syndrome verraten uns
etwas über den aufgetretenen Fehler – und insbesondere, wenn wir wissen, dass einer dieser vier möglichen Fehler
aufgetreten ist, zeigt uns das Syndrom, welcher es war, und wir können ihn korrigieren, indem wir den Fehler erneut anwenden, wenn wir
möchten. Als Nächstes möchte ich noch ein bisschen mehr über die Syndrome sagen, und insbesondere werden wir einen genaueren Blick auf
ihre algebraischen Aspekte werfen. Unsere Kodierungen sind Drei-qubit-Zustände, also Einheitsvektoren in einem
achtdimensionalen komplexen Vektorraum, und was die vier möglichen Syndrome tun, ist diesen achtdimensionalen Raum
in vier zweidimensionale Unterräume aufzuteilen, was bedeutet, dass die Vektoren in einem dieser Unterräume uns immer dasselbe
Syndrom liefern. Genauer gesagt veranschaulicht dieses Diagramm, wie der achtdimensionale Raum aufgeteilt wird:
Jeder Stabilisatorgenerator teilt den Raum in zwei Unterräume gleicher Dimension – nämlich den Raum der Plus-Eins-
Eigenvektoren und den Raum der Minus-Eins-Eigenvektoren. Zum Beispiel sind die Plus-Eins-Vektoren von ZZ-Identität Linearkombinationen
von Standardbasisvektoren, bei denen die beiden ganz linken Bits gerade Parität haben, und die Minus-Eins-Eigenvektoren sind Linear-
kombinationen von Standardbasisvektoren, bei denen die beiden ganz linken Bits ungerade Parität haben. Die Situation ist ähnlich für
den anderen Stabilisatorgenerator, außer dass es die beiden ganz rechten Bits sind statt der beiden ganz linken. Diese vier Unterräume sind also einfach zu
beschreiben in diesem Fall, da es sich um einen sehr einfachen Code handelt. Insbesondere ist der Unterraum,
der dem Syndrom plus eins, plus eins entspricht, der von |000⟩ und |111⟩ aufgespannte Raum, also der Raum der gültigen
Kodierungen, und dieser wird der Code-Raum genannt. Im Allgemeinen werden die Räume von den Standardbasisvektoren aufgespannt,
die in den entsprechenden Feldern gezeigt werden, obwohl es nicht unbedingt so klar oder leicht zu erkennen ist. Die Syndrome
partitionieren auch alle Drei-qubit-Poly-Operationen, die die möglichen Poly-Fehler darstellen, die auftreten könnten, in vier gleich große Gruppen,
abhängig davon, welches Syndrom dieser Fehler verursachen würde. Zum Beispiel ergibt jede Poly-Operation,
die mit beiden Stabilisatorgeneratoren kommutiert, das Syndrom plus eins, plus eins, und unter den 64 möglichen Drei-
qubit-Poly-Operationen gibt es genau 16 in dieser Kategorie, einschließlich der drei, die auf dem Bildschirm erwähnt werden – und entsprechend für die anderen drei
Syndrome. Das ist nicht offensichtlich, aber es ist wahr, und diese grundlegende Eigenschaft, dass die Syndrome sowohl den Zustandsraum,
in dem die Kodierungen leben, als auch alle möglichen Poly-Fehler im Raum in gleich große Teile aufteilen, ist etwas, das
im Allgemeinen für Stabilizer-Codes gilt, die wir bald genau definieren werden, obwohl es an dieser Stelle
hauptsächlich nur eine Randbemerkung ist. Es ist erwähnenswert, dass Pauli-Operationen, die mit beiden Stabilizer-Generatoren kommutieren, oder gleichwertig
Pauli-Operationen, die das Syndrom +1 +1 erzeugen, aber selbst nicht proportional zu Elementen des Stabilizers sind, sich genau wie
einzelne qubit-Pauli-Operationen auf dem logischen qubit verhalten, das wir kodiert haben. Zum Beispiel kommutiert XXX mit
beiden Stabilizer-Generatoren, ist aber nicht proportional zu einem Element des Stabilizers, und es ist tatsächlich klar, wenn du
diesen Code einen Moment lang betrachtest, dass die Wirkung, die diese Operation auf eine Kodierung hat, äquivalent zu einem X gate auf
dem kodierten logischen qubit ist. Und auch das lässt sich auf alle Stabilizer-Codes verallgemeinern. Jetzt ist es an der Zeit, Stabilizer-
Codes im Allgemeinen zu definieren. Die Funktionsweise ist vollständig analog zu dem, was wir gerade für den
3-Bit-Wiederholungscode besprochen haben, mit dem Unterschied, dass wir verschiedene Stabilizer-Generatoren wählen, auf die ich als P1
bis PR verweisen werde. Für diese Erklärung müssen alle diese Stabilizer-Generatoren n-qubit-Pauli-Operationen sein,
wobei n die Anzahl der qubits ist, die für die Kodierung verwendet werden. Und wir können nicht einfach irgendeine Menge von Stabilizer-Generatoren wählen – sie
müssen einige grundlegende Bedingungen erfüllen. Erstens müssen alle Stabilizer-Generatoren miteinander
kommutieren. Im Fall des 3-Bit-Wiederholungscodes haben wir das nicht eigens vermerkt, aber es ist einfach zu beobachten, dass ZZ-Identität und Identität-
ZZ tatsächlich kommutieren, weil Z mit sich selbst kommutiert und alles mit der
Identität kommutiert. Bei Stabilizer-Codes mit komplizierteren Stabilizer-Generatoren andererseits, einschließlich Codes, bei denen wir sowohl
X's als auch Z's in den Stabilizer-Generatoren haben, ist dies eine wichtige Bedingung, die
überprüft werden muss. Eine Möglichkeit, den Bedarf an dieser Bedingung zu verstehen, ist, dass wir die Stabilizer-Generatoren als Observablen behandeln werden, und indem wir verlangen, dass
sie alle kommutieren, stellen wir sicher, dass die Reihenfolge, in der wir diese Messungen durchführen,
keine Rolle spielt. Zweitens müssen die Stabilizer-Generatoren eine sogenannte minimale Erzeugendenmenge bilden, was bedeutet, dass wenn wir einen
davon entfernen würden, wir einen kleineren Stabilizer erhalten würden. Eine Möglichkeit, dies mathematisch auszudrücken, ist hier auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt. Streng genommen ist diese Bedingung nicht wirklich wesentlich für die Funktionsweise eines Stabilizer-Codes in einem operationellen
Sinne, und manchmal macht es Sinn, über nicht-minimale Erzeugendenmengen nachzudenken, wie wir in der nächsten Lektion sehen werden. Aber
um Stabilizer-Codes zu analysieren und ihre Eigenschaften zu erklären, werden wir annehmen, dass diese Bedingung erfüllt
ist. Im Wesentlichen garantiert diese Bedingung, dass jede Observable, die wir messen, um das Syndrom zu erhalten, neue
Informationen über mögliche Fehler hinzufügt, anstatt redundant zu sein und Ergebnisse zu liefern, die leicht aus den anderen Stabilizer-Generatoren als
Observablen abgeleitet werden könnten. Und schließlich muss es der Fall sein, dass mindestens ein Nicht-Null-Vektor von allen
Stabilizer-Generatoren fixiert wird. Das ist äquivalent zur Forderung, dass -1 mal die Identität auf N qubits
nicht im Stabilizer enthalten ist. Das ist nicht offensichtlich, aber der Punkt ist, dass es möglich ist, eine minimale Erzeugendenmenge
von n-qubit-Pauli-Operationen zu wählen, die alle miteinander kommutieren, und dennoch ist kein Vektor gleichzeitig ein +1-Eigen-
vektor von allen. Und wir wollen uns nicht mit dieser Möglichkeit befassen, weil Codes ohne gültige Kodierungen
nicht interessant sind. Das sind also die Anforderungen an die Stabilizer-Generatoren für einen Stabilizer-Code. Und wenn wir eine Menge von Generatoren haben, die
diese Bedingungen erfüllen, haben wir einen gültigen Stabilizer-Code und können seine Eigenschaften betrachten. Es gibt viele
verschiedene Stabilizer-Codes mit verschiedenen Eigenschaften, die sie interessant machen oder nicht, aber sie alle erfüllen bestimmte grundlegende
Eigenschaften, die an die erinnern, die wir bereits für den 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode beobachtet haben.
Wir werden uns bald einige Beispiele ansehen, aber zuvor möchte ich erwähnen, dass wenn wir uns auf den Code-Raum eines Stabilizer-Codes beziehen, wir den Teilraum meinen,
des N-qubit-Zustandsraums, der jeden Vektor einschließt, der gleichzeitig ein +1-Eigenvektor von jedem der
Stabilizer-Generatoren ist. Dies ist der Teilraum des n-qubit-Zustandsraums, in dem gültige Kodierungen leben, und wir werden noch mehr über
diesen Teilraum sagen, während die Lektion fortschreitet. Schauen wir uns jetzt ein paar Beispiele von Stabilizer-
Codes an. Hier ist das Beispiel, das wir bereits besprochen haben: der gewöhnliche 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode. Und wir können auch die
modifizierte Version dieses Codes aus der vorherigen Lektion ausdrücken, die einen Phasenfehler statt eines Bitfehlers erkennen kann, als Stabilizer-Code, wie gezeigt
wird. Diesmal messen die Stabilizer-Generatoren XX-Observablen statt ZZ-Observablen, also handelt es sich im Wesentlichen um
Paritätsprüfungen in der Plus-Minus-Basis statt der Standardbasis. In beiden Fällen können wir
sofort erkennen, dass wir einen gültigen Stabilizer-Code haben, weil die Stabilizer-Generatoren kommutieren, es sich um minimale
Erzeugendenmengen handelt und der Code-Raum nicht-trivial ist, wie wir bereits wissen. Aber wir können auch ziemlich klar sehen, dass wir
-1 mal die Identität nicht erzeugen können. Und hier ist der 9-qubit-Shore-Code, der ebenfalls ein Stabilizer-Code ist,
ausgedrückt durch Stabilizer-Generatoren. In diesem Fall haben wir im Wesentlichen drei Kopien des 3-Bit-
Wiederholungscodes, eine für jeden der drei Blöcke aus drei qubits, sowie die letzten zwei Stabilizer-Generatoren, die
eine Form annehmen, die an den circuit erinnert, den wir in der vorherigen Lektion zur Erkennung von Phasenfehlern gesehen haben. Für diesen
Code ist eine weitere Möglichkeit, über diese letzten zwei Stabilizer-Generatoren nachzudenken, dass sie genau dieselbe Form annehmen wie beim
3-Bit-Wiederholungscode für Phasenfehler, außer dass wir XXX für X einsetzen. Und der Grund dafür ist,
dass XXX einer X-Operation auf dem logischen qubit entspricht, das mit dem 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode kodiert wurde. Aber
das ist eine Randbemerkung und muss jetzt nicht beachtet werden. Falls es nicht klar ist, werden wir uns als nächstes ein paar
weitere Beispiele ansehen. Aber zuvor möchte ich erwähnen, dass man oft die Tensorprodukt-Symbole weglässt, wenn man Stabilizer-Codes beschreibt, weil sie
dadurch leichter zu lesen sind. Hier sehen diese Codes ohne die Tensorprodukt-Symbole aus.
Natürlich sind das Tensorprodukte und keine gewöhnlichen Matrizenprodukte – wir lassen die Tensorprodukt-Symbole nur weg, damit es weniger
überfüllt ist und die Muster klarer werden. Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel. Es wird
der 7-qubit-Steane-Code genannt und hat einige bemerkenswerte Eigenschaften. Wir werden auf diesen Code
im Laufe der verbleibenden Lektionen der Einheit immer wieder zurückkommen, aber für jetzt können wir einfach überprüfen, dass es ein gültiger Stabilizer-
Code ist. Insbesondere kommutieren die ersten drei Stabilizer-Generatoren eindeutig miteinander, weil Z mit
sich selbst kommutiert und die Identität mit allem kommutiert. Und die Situation ist ähnlich für die letzten drei. Es bleibt also zu
prüfen, ob, wenn wir einen der Z-Stabilizer-Generatoren und einen der X-Stabilizer-Generatoren nehmen, diese kommutieren.
Und es ist einfach genug, die neun möglichen Paarungen durchzugehen, um zu überprüfen, dass wir in all diesen Fällen immer
ein X und ein Z an der gleichen Position eine gerade Anzahl von Malen übereinstimmen, sodass die zwei Generatoren kommutieren werden, genauso wie
XX und ZZ kommutieren. Es ist eine minimale Erzeugendenmenge und hat einen nichttrivialen Codespace, aber
ich werde das in diesem Video nicht zu beweisen versuchen, sondern überlasse es dir zum Nachdenken, wenn du möchtest. Der 7-qubit Steane-Code ist ähnlich
wie der 9-qubit Shore-Code in dem Sinne, dass er ein einzelnes qubit codiert und die Korrektur eines beliebigen Fehlers auf einem qubit ermöglicht, aber er benötigt nur
sieben qubits anstatt neun. Das ist nicht die geringste Anzahl von qubits, die für einen fehlerkorrigierenden Code erforderlich ist,
um ein qubit zu codieren und einen beliebigen Fehler auf einem einzelnen qubit zu korrigieren. Hier ist ein Stabilizer-Code, der
normalerweise einfach als Fünf-qubit-Code bezeichnet wird, der ebenfalls ein einzelnes qubit codiert und einen beliebigen Einzelqubit-Fehler korrigieren kann.
Fünf ist die kleinste Anzahl von qubits, für die das möglich ist. Hier ist ein weiteres Beispiel für einen
Stabilizer-Code, obwohl er im eigentlichen Sinne kein Code ist, da der Codespace
eindimensional ist. Insbesondere ist der Codespace für diesen Code der Raum, der von einem ebit aufgespannt wird, oder mit anderen Worten einem Phi-plus-
Bell-Zustand. Du kannst also mit diesem Code keine qubits codieren, aber er ist trotzdem ein gültiger Stabilizer-Code, bei dem der Code-
space zufällig eindimensional ist. Und es ist möglich, etwas Ähnliches für einen GHZ-
Zustand zu tun. Das sind also einige Beispiele für Stabilizer-Codes, und wir werden in der
nächsten Lektion unendlich viele weitere Beispiele sehen. Angenommen, uns wird ein Stabilizer-Code gegeben – eine naheliegende Frage, die man stellen könnte,
vielleicht die allererste Frage, die einem in den Sinn kommt: Wie viele qubits codiert er? Diese Frage hat eine sehr einfache
Antwort, und um sie zu erklären, wollen wir den betrachteten Stabilizer-Code präzise beschreiben. Wir haben R N-qubit-
Stabilizer-Generatoren P1 bis Pr, die die drei Anforderungen erfüllen, die ich zuvor erwähnt habe, nämlich dass die
Stabilizer-Generatoren alle miteinander kommutieren. Dies ist eine minimale Erzeugendenmenge, sodass wir nicht den gleichen
Stabilizer erhalten würden, wenn wir einen der Generatoren entfernen, und es gibt mindestens einen Nullvektor im Codespace.
Wie das auf dem Bildschirm gezeigte Theorem zeigt, muss dann gelten, dass der Codespace des Stabilizer-Codes die
Dimension 2^(n-r) hat. Oder anders ausgedrückt: Wir können n
minus r qubits mit diesem Code codieren. Intuitiv gesprochen haben wir n qubits in unserer Kodierung, und jeder
Stabilizer-Generator nimmt effektiv ein qubit weg, in Bezug darauf, wie viele qubits wir codieren können.
Dieses Theorem ist nicht allzu schwer zu beweisen, und ich zeige dir gleich einen Beweis, aber zuerst schauen wir uns kurz
einige Beispiele an, beginnend mit dem gewöhnlichen 3-Bit-Wiederholungscode. Wir haben drei qubits in unserer
Kodierung, also ist n gleich drei, und es gibt R gleich 2 Stabilizer-Generatoren, sodass wir ein
qubit mit diesem Code codieren können. Beachte, dass es dabei nicht darum geht, welche oder wie viele Fehler erkannt oder
korrigiert werden können – das ist eine andere Sache. Dies ist lediglich eine Aussage über die Dimension des Codespaces.
Als weiteres Beispiel betrachten wir den 5-qubit-Code. Hier haben wir fünf qubits und vier
Stabilizer-Generatoren, sodass der Codespace erneut die Dimension zwei hat, was bedeutet, dass wir ein qubit mit diesem
Code codieren können. Und noch ein Beispiel: Beim ebit-Stabilizer-Code haben wir zwei qubits und zwei Stabilizer-Generatoren,
sodass der Codespace eindimensional ist, und wie ich zuvor erwähnt habe, ist es der Raum, der vom Phi-plus-Bell-Zustand aufgespannt wird.
Wir werden weitere Beispiele sehen, wenn wir fortfahren, einschließlich Codes, bei denen wir mehr als ein qubit codieren können. Aber jetzt wollen wir
sehen, wie wir das Theorem beweisen können. Das Erste, was wir beobachten müssen, ist, dass die Stabilizer-
Generatoren kommutieren und eine minimale Erzeugendenmenge bilden, und da jede Pauli-Operation ihre eigene Inverse ist, kann jedes
Element im Stabilizer auf eindeutige Weise als Produkt ausgedrückt werden, bei dem wir jeden Stabilizer-Generator
Pk zur Potenz Ak erheben, wobei jedes Ak entweder null oder eins ist, und dann die Ergebnisse
multiplizieren. Anders ausgedrückt erhalten wir jedes Element des Stabilizers, indem wir eine Teilmenge der
Stabilizer-Generatoren miteinander multiplizieren, und wir erhalten dasselbe Stabilizer-Element nie aus verschiedenen Teilmengen. Und etwas, was das
impliziert, ist: Die einzige Möglichkeit, die N-qubit-Identitätsoperation auf diese Weise auszudrücken, besteht darin, alle Potenzen auf null zu setzen.
Als nächstes definieren wir pi_k als die Projektion auf den Plus-eins-Eigenraum von Pk für jedes k von 1 bis R. Und dafür gibt es
eine einfache Formel: Wir können einfach Pk mit der Identität auf N qubits mitteln, was effektiv die Plus-eins-
Eigenwerte unverändert lässt und alle Minus-eins-Eigenwerte auf null verschiebt.
Nun ist der Codespace definiert als die Menge aller Vektoren, die gleichzeitig Plus-eins-Eigenvektoren aller
Stabilizer-Generatoren sind. Da die Stabilizer-Generatoren kommutieren, müssen auch die Projektionen kommutieren, und das
impliziert, dass das Produkt dieser Projektionen ebenfalls eine Projektion ist – insbesondere ist es die Projektion auf den
Schnitt der Unterräume, auf die die einzelnen Projektionen projizieren, oder mit anderen Worten: Es ist die Projektion auf
den Codespace. Wir können dieses Produkt ausmultiplizieren und erhalten den Durchschnitt über jedes
Element des Stabilizers. Und schließlich: Da die Dimension eines beliebigen Unterraums gleich der
Spur der Projektion auf diesen Unterraum ist, stellen wir fest, dass die Dimension des Codespace der Durchschnitt der Spuren über die Elemente des
Stabilizers ist. Aber mit Ausnahme der N-qubit-Identitätsoperation müssen alle Elemente des Stabilizers die
Spur null haben, da alle drei Nicht-Identitäts-Pauli-Matrizen die Spur null haben. Die Spur der N-qubit-Identitäts-
operation ist 2^n, und so stellen wir fest, dass die Dimension des Codespace 2^(n-r) ist, was das
Theorem beweist. Als nächstes sage ich nur kurz etwas darüber, wie qubits mit Stabilizer-Codes codiert werden können. Dafür müssen wir aber zunächst
Clifford-Operationen einführen. Clifford-Operationen sind unitäre Operationen auf einer beliebigen Anzahl von
qubits, die durch Quantencircuits mit einer eingeschränkten Menge von gates implementiert werden können, nämlich Hadamard-gates, S-gates
und CNOT-gates. Beachte, dass T-gates nicht enthalten sind, ebenso wenig wie Toffoli-gates oder Fredkin-
gates. Und nicht nur sind diese gates nicht in dieser Liste enthalten, es ist tatsächlich auch nicht möglich, diese gates
mit den hier aufgeführten zu implementieren. Sie sind also keine Clifford-Operationen. Pauli-Operationen hingegen
sind Clifford-Operationen, und speziell können sie mit Sequenzen von Hadamard- und S-
gates implementiert werden. Das ist also eine einfache Möglichkeit, Clifford-Operationen zu definieren, aber es erklärt nicht wirklich, warum sie so definiert werden
oder was an dieser speziellen Sammlung von gates besonders ist. Hier ist der eigentliche Grund, warum Clifford-Operationen so definiert werden, wie
bis auf eine globale Phase sind die n-qubit Clifford-Operationen genau die unitären
Operationen, die Pauli-Operationen durch Konjugation immer in Pauli-Operationen umwandeln. Genauer gesagt ist eine n-bit
unitäre Operation U eine Clifford-Operation bis auf einen globalen Phasenfaktor genau dann, wenn für jede n-qubit Pauli-
Operation die Konjugation dieser Pauli-Operation durch U uns plus oder minus eins mal eine möglicherweise andere n-
qubit Pauli-Operation ergibt. Du kannst leicht überprüfen, dass diese Eigenschaft für Hadamard gates, S
gates und CNOT gates gilt. Sie gilt also zwangsläufig für circuits, die aus diesen gates aufgebaut sind. Was schwieriger zu beweisen ist, ist dass es
auch in die andere Richtung geht, nämlich dass wenn uns eine bestimmte n-bit unitäre Operation U gegeben ist, die diese
Eigenschaft erfüllt, dann muss es möglich sein, sie bis auf eine globale Phase nur mit Hadamard, S und CNOT
gates zu implementieren. Ich werde den Beweis dieser Implikation nicht durchgehen, aber er ist wahr und du kannst ihn nachschlagen, wenn du
interessiert bist. Clifford-Operationen sind nicht universell für Quantenberechnungen, was bedeutet, dass wir keine beliebigen
Quantenberechnungen nur mit Hadamard, S und CNOT gates durchführen können. Tatsächlich gibt es für einen gegebenen Wert von n nur endlich viele
n-qubit Clifford-Operationen, also ist es eine diskrete Menge von Operationen. Im Gegensatz zu einem
universellen Satz von Quantum gates können wir also keine beliebigen unitären Operationen auf jede gewünschte Genauigkeit annähern. Und
tatsächlich können Clifford-Operationen auf Standardbasiszuständen gefolgt von Standardbasismessungen keine
Berechnungen ermöglichen, die außerhalb der Reichweite klassischer Algorithmen liegen, weil wir Berechnungen dieser Form effizient simulieren können
klassisch. Diese Tatsache ist als das Gottesman-Knill-Theorem bekannt und der Standardbeweis dieses Theorems basiert in gewissem Sinne
auf dem Stabilisatorformalismus. Die Art und Weise, wie es funktioniert, ist insbesondere, dass wir verfolgen können, wie Clifford-Operationen Pauli-
Operationen durch Konjugation transformieren, was effizient durchgeführt werden kann, und dann daraus ableiten, was die Berechnungen mit den
qubits machen. Also, was hat das mit Stabilisatorcodes zu tun? Ein Stabilisatorcode bietet uns
einen Coderaum einer bestimmten Dimension, und wir haben die Freiheit, diesen Coderaum nach Belieben zu verwenden. Nichts zwingt uns also dazu,
qubits auf eine bestimmte Weise in diesen Raum zu kodieren, aber es wird immer möglich sein, eine Kodierung mit einer Clifford-Operation
als Kodierer durchzuführen. Das ist schön, weil Clifford-Operationen im Vergleich zu beliebigen unitären
Operationen relativ einfach sind. Es gibt Möglichkeiten, ihre Implementierung zu optimieren, was ähnlich wie der Beweis des Gottesman-
Knill-Theorems verläuft, und als Ergebnis müssen circuits zu ihrer Implementierung nie besonders
groß sein. Insbesondere können wir eine Kodierung mit einer Clifford-Operation immer mit etwas weniger als einer quadratischen Anzahl von gates durchführen,
weil das tatsächlich für jede Clifford-Operation gilt. Das Fazit ist also, dass es für einen gegebenen Stabilisatorcode immer
möglich ist, qubits effizient mit diesem Code zu kodieren, und die mathematischen Werkzeuge, die zum Verständnis von Clifford-Operationen nützlich sind, können dabei helfen
Prozess. Hier ist zum Beispiel ein Kodierer für den 7-qubit Steane-Code. Es ist eine Clifford-Operation, und wie sich herausstellt,
braucht dieser nicht einmal S gates. Für allgemeine Stabilisatorcodes funktioniert die Fehlererkennung wie folgt:
Wie zuvor nehmen wir an, dass wir n-qubit Stabilisatorgeneratoren P1 bis Pr haben, und wir lassen E eine n-qubit Pauli-
Operation sein, die einen hypothetischen Fehler bei einer Kodierung darstellt. Wir betrachten dabei nur Pauli-
Operationen als Fehler, weil die Diskretisierung von Fehlern für beliebige Stabilisatorcodes genauso funktioniert wie für den 9-qubit Shore-
Code. Die Art, wie wir auf Fehler prüfen, besteht darin, jeden der Stabilisatorgeneratoren als
Observablen zu messen. Es gibt R Stabilisatorgeneratoren, also bedeutet das R Ergebnisse, wobei jedes plus eins oder minus
eins ist, oder ein binärer Wert, wenn du es vorziehst, null mit plus eins und eins mit minus eins zu verknüpfen. Und diese R Ergebnisse
bilden zusammen das Syndrom, genau wie beim Drei-Bit-Wiederholungscode, als R gleich
zwei war. Im Allgemeinen gibt es drei mögliche Fälle für den Fehler E in Bezug auf seine Erkennung, die wie folgt lauten. Erstens
könnte es sein, dass E im Stabilisator liegt, was bedeutet, dass es möglich ist, E aus den Stabilisatorgeneratoren zu erzeugen, oder
etwas allgemeiner könnte es sein, dass E bis auf eine globale Phase äquivalent zu einem Stabilisatorelement ist.
In diesem Fall ist E eigentlich überhaupt kein Fehler, weil es im Coderaum keine Auswirkung hat, außer möglicherweise
eine globale Phase einzufügen, was keinen Effekt hat. Wir müssen uns also überhaupt keine Sorgen über solche Fehler machen.
Eine nicht-triviale Wirkung, die es haben könnte, findet außerhalb des Coderaums statt, also betrifft es uns
nicht. Viel mehr Sorgen bereitet die Möglichkeit, dass E nicht im Stabilisator liegt, auch nicht bis auf eine globale Phase, aber
dennoch mit jedem einzelnen unserer Stabilisatorgeneratoren kommutiert. Denk daran, dass es die
Antikommutation des Fehlers mit einem Stabilisatorgenerator ist, die dazu führt, dass eine minus Eins irgendwo im Syndrom erscheint,
aber das passiert in diesem Fall nicht. Das ist also ein Fehler, der tatsächlich Vektoren im Coderaum auf eine
nicht-triviale Weise verändert, und das wissen wir, weil er sonst proportional zu einem Stabilisatorelement wäre. Aber er wird
vom Code nicht erkannt. Das ist also der schlimme Fall: Wir haben einen Fehler, der möglicherweise das
Quanteninformation, das wir kodiert haben, verändert, aber der Code ist sich dieser Tatsache nicht bewusst. Zum Beispiel fällt beim Drei-Bit-
Wiederholungscode XXX in diese Kategorie. Die letzte Möglichkeit ist, dass E
mit mindestens einem der Stabilisatorgeneratoren antikommutiert, was bedeutet, dass der Code diesen Fehler erkennt, weil
wir ein Syndrom mit mindestens einer minus Eins darin erhalten, was anzeigt, dass etwas nicht stimmt, und wir versuchen müssen, diesen Fehler zu korrigieren
irgendwie. Das sind also die Möglichkeiten. Als Terminologiepunkt:
Wenn wir von der Distanz eines Stabilisatorcodes sprechen, meinen wir das minimale Gewicht einer Pauli-Operation, die in die
zweite Kategorie fällt, was bedeutet, dass sie den Coderaum auf eine nicht-triviale Weise verändert, der Code sie aber nicht
erkennt. Und wenn wir sagen, dass ein Stabilisatorcode ein [[n,m,d]] Stabilisatorcode ist,
mit doppelten eckigen Klammern wie auf dem Bildschirm gezeigt, bedeutet das, dass Kodierungen n qubits lang sind.
Der Code ist in der Lage, m qubits zu kodieren, sodass der Coderaum die Dimension 2^m hat, und seine Distanz ist d. Ein Fehler muss also
Gewicht d oder mehr haben, um den logischen Zustand eines qubit, das wir kodiert haben, zu verändern, ohne als
Fehler erkannt zu werden. Wir werden uns jetzt den 7-qubit Steane-Code als Beispiel ansehen und seine Distanz
bestimmen. Hier sind die Stabilisatorgeneratoren für diesen Code, und denk daran, dass die Distanz das minimale Gewicht einer
n-qubit Pauli-Operation ist, die mit allen Stabilisatorgeneratoren kommutiert, aber selbst nicht im Stabilisator ist, noch
ist es proportional zu einem Element des Stabilisators – was wir bestimmen werden, ist, dass dieser Code die Distanz
drei hat. Die Art, wie wir das bestimmen werden, besteht darin, zunächst jede Pauli-Operation mit einem Gewicht von höchstens zwei zu betrachten, und wir werden
zu dem Schluss kommen, dass die einzige Möglichkeit, wie sie mit allen sechs Stabilisatorgeneratoren vertauschen kann, darin besteht, dass sie die Identität ist, die immer ein Element des
Stabilisators ist. Nehmen wir also an, dass die möglicherweise nicht-trivialen Pauli-Matrizen, die diese Operation bilden, und die wir
P und Q nennen werden, in den zwei linksten Positionen erscheinen. Das ist nur ein Fall, und wir müssen
auch alle anderen möglichen Positionen für diese möglicherweise nicht-trivialen Pauli-Matrizen berücksichtigen, aber das Argument ist im Wesentlichen dasselbe für alle
möglichen Positionen. Nach Annahme vertauscht diese Operation mit allen Stabilisatorgeneratoren,
also vertauscht sie insbesondere mit diesem hier und auch mit diesem
hier. Q stimmt in beiden dieser Generatoren mit der Identitätsmatrix überein, weshalb wir diese beiden gewählt haben, und wir haben Identitäts-
matrizen in den fünf rechtesten Positionen dieses Fehlers, und so schließen wir, dass P sowohl mit X
als auch mit Z vertauschen muss – andernfalls würde dieser Fehler mit einem dieser beiden Generatoren antivertauschen. Aber die einzige Pauli-Matrix, die
mit sowohl X als auch Z vertauscht, ist die Identität. Also muss P die Identität sein, und jetzt, wo wir das wissen,
können wir zwei weitere Stabilisatorgeneratoren wählen, die ein X und ein Z in der zweiten Position von links haben, und wir können
eine ähnliche Schlussfolgerung über Q ziehen. Es gibt also keine Möglichkeit, dass ein Fehler mit Gewicht höchstens 2 von diesem Code unentdeckt bleibt,
es sei denn, es ist die Identitätsoperation, die sich im Stabilisator befindet – das ist also eigentlich kein
Fehler. Andererseits gibt es Pauli-Operationen mit Gewicht drei, die mit allen sechs dieser Stabilisatorgeneratoren vertauschen,
aber nicht proportional zu Stabilisatorelementen sind. Und hier sind zwei Beispiele. Damit haben wir festgestellt, dass dieser
Code die Distanz drei hat. Das Letzte, was wir in dieser Lektion besprechen werden, ist die Fehlerkorrektur für
Stabilisatorcodes. Wie üblich nehmen wir an, dass unser Code durch n-Bit-Stabilisatorgeneratoren spezifiziert ist.
P1 bis Pn. Lass uns zunächst ein wenig über alle möglichen Fehler nachdenken, die auftreten könnten.
Es gibt 2 hoch r mögliche Syndrome, und wie ich früher in der Lektion erwähnt habe, teilen diese Syndrome alle
möglichen n-qubit-Pauli-Operationen in gleich große Mengen auf. Das bedeutet, dass es 4 hoch N geteilt durch 2 hoch r Pauli-Operationen
in jeder Menge gibt. Wenn wir also ein bestimmtes Syndrom sehen, könnte es sein, dass irgendeiner dieser 4 hoch N geteilt durch 2
hoch r Fehler dafür verantwortlich ist. Wir zählen hier allerdings etwas zu viel, denn einige dieser
Fehler haben genau denselben Effekt auf den Codespace. Insbesondere wenn wir einen Fehler E haben und E mit einem beliebigen
Stabilisatorelement S multiplizieren, erhalten wir einen anderen Fehler, der genau denselben Effekt im Codespace hat wie E.
Diese Fehler sind also äquivalent. Der Stabilisator hat 2 hoch r Elemente, und wenn wir dies berücksichtigen, stellen wir fest,
dass es für jedes Syndrom 4 hoch N minus r Äquivalenzklassen von Fehlern gibt, die dieses eine
Syndrom verursacht haben könnten. Und das bedeutet, dass es – es sei denn, r ist gleich n, was einen eindimensionalen Codespace bedeutet und
daher keine qubits kodieren kann – nicht möglich sein wird, jeden erkennbaren Fehler zu korrigieren. Stattdessen
müssen wir für jedes Syndrom genau eine Korrekturop­eration wählen in der Hoffnung, nur eine Klasse äquivalenter
Fehler zu korrigieren. Wie sollen wir also wählen, welche Korrektur für jedes Syndrom durchzuführen ist? Eine naheliegende Strategie ist, die
Pauli-Operation mit dem niedrigsten Gewicht zu wählen, die das gemessene Syndrom verursacht – mit der Idee, dass Pauli-Operationen mit geringerem Gewicht
wahrscheinlichere Erklärungen für das Syndrom darstellen. Das muss für einige Rauschmodelle nicht unbedingt der Fall sein,
und eine weitere naheliegende Strategie ist, irgendwie den wahrscheinlichsten Fehler zu berechnen, der das
gegebene Syndrom verursacht. Aber fürs Erste betrachten wir nur die Strategie, bei der wir versuchen, Fehler zu korrigieren, indem wir die Pauli-Operation mit dem niedrigsten Gewicht wählen, die das
Syndrom verursacht. Bei einem Stabilisatorcode mit Distanz D erlaubt uns diese Strategie immer, Fehler zu korrigieren, deren Gewicht strikt
kleiner als die Hälfte von D ist – oder anders gesagt, Gewicht höchstens (D minus 1) durch 2. Ich erkläre kurz, warum das
so ist. Das wird zum Beispiel zeigen, dass der 7-qubit-Steane-Code jeden Pauli-Fehler mit Gewicht eins korrigieren kann, und durch die
Diskretisierung von Fehlern bedeutet das, dass der Steane-Code – genau wie der 9-qubit-Shor-Code – einen beliebigen
Fehler auf einem qubit korrigieren kann. So funktioniert das: Stell dir vor, dieser Kreis repräsentiert alle möglichen Pauli-
Operationen, die das All-Plus-1-Syndrom ergeben – das Syndrom, das darauf hindeutet, dass keine Fehler aufgetreten sind
und nichts falsch ist. Unter diesen Operationen haben wir Elemente des Stabilisators – oder eigentlich
Operationen, die proportional zu Elementen des Stabilisators sind – und wir haben auch nicht-triviale Fehler, die den Codespace irgendwie verändern, aber nicht
vom Code erkannt werden. Und wir wissen per Definition der Distanz, dass jede Pauli-Operation in dieser Kategorie Gewicht mindestens
D haben muss, denn D ist definiert als das Minimalgewicht dieser Operationen. Wir haben auch Pauli-Operationen,
die andere Syndrome hervorrufen, und wir könnten jedes Syndrom der Reihe nach betrachten, wenn wir wollen. Aber hier stellen wir uns nur vor,
dass ein solches Syndrom s aufgetaucht ist. Stell dir jetzt vor, dass E ein Fehler in dieser
Kategorie ist, der Gewicht strikt kleiner als die Hälfte der Distanz D hat. Wir wissen nicht, dass das
notwendigerweise die Pauli-Operation mit dem Minimalgewicht in diesem Kreis ist. Also nehmen wir C als die Operation mit dem Minimalgewicht in dieser Menge – oder eine davon, falls es ein Gleichstand gibt.
Es könnte also sein, dass C gleich E ist oder möglicherweise nicht. Aber weil C
Minimalgewicht hat, wissen wir, dass sein Gewicht nicht größer sein kann als das Gewicht von E, weil C ebenfalls in der Menge ist
und Minimalgewicht hat. Also muss die Korrekturop­eration C Gewicht strikt kleiner als die Hälfte von
D haben. Was passiert also, wenn wir diese Korrektur C auf den Zustand anwenden, den wir nach dem Fehler E
erhalten? Die Antwort ist, dass der Zustand, den wir erhalten, C mal E multipliziert auf die ursprüngliche Kodierung ist, weil wir zunächst
mit E multipliziert haben – das war der Fehler – und dann mit C, um ihn zu korrigieren. Und dieses Produkt muss im
Stabilisator liegen oder proportional zu einem Element des Stabilisators sein. Und hier ist der Grund: Erstens, weil E und C uns das
gleiche Syndrom geben, muss C mal E das All-Plus-1-Syndrom ergeben. Das liegt daran, dass für einen gegebenen
Stabilisatorgenerator entweder C und E beide mit diesem Generator vertauschen oder beide antivertauschen – es muss für
beide gleich sein, weil die Syndrome gleich sind. Und wenn du das einen Moment lang durchdenkst, folgt daraus, dass C mal E mit
allen Stabilisatorgeneratoren vertauschen muss. Und schließlich muss C mal E
im Stabilisator liegen, weil sein Gewicht nicht größer als die Summe der Gewichte von C und E sein kann, sodass sein Gewicht
strikt kleiner als D ist. Und das bedeutet, dass wir E erfolgreich korrigieren, weil die Anwendung von E gefolgt von C nichts am
Codespace ändert. Das ist großartig, aber es gibt nur ein Problem: Bei Stabilisatorcodes
im Allgemeinen ist es ein rechnerisch schwieriges Problem, die Operation mit dem niedrigsten Gewicht zu berechnen, die ein gegebenes
Syndrom verursacht. Und das gilt sogar für klassische Codes, die wir in diesem Kontext als Stabilisatorcodes betrachten können,
bei denen nur Identitätsmatrizen und Z-Pauli-Matrizen als Tensorfaktoren innerhalb der Stabilisatoren auftreten.
Generatoren. Also kommen uns – anders als beim Kodierungsschritt – Clifford-Operationen diesmal nicht zu Hilfe, und die einzige vernünftige
Lösung ist, spezifische Codes zu wählen, für die gute Korrekturen effizient berechnet werden können. Und dafür gibt es kein Rezept –
kurz gesagt: das Entwickeln solcher Stabilisatorcodes ist Teil der Kunst
des Quantencode-Designs. Und das ist ein guter Punkt, um diese Lektion zu beenden. Ich hoffe, du wirst dich mir
in der nächsten Lektion anschließen, in der wir uns einige spezifische Quantencode-Konstruktionen ansehen werden, einschließlich Codes, die die Kunst des Quantencode-
Designs auf ziemlich spektakuläre Weise veranschaulichen. Auf Wiedersehen bis dann.